all right we got one more and uh spencer
you mentioned winning and uh this was a
particularly good week for that orange
man who used to always talk about
winning
22 of 22 candidates that donald trump
endorsed in these uh primaries over the
last week or so uh one 22 out of 22. i'm
not a mathemagician but i think that's a
hundred percent uh the big one and we've
got a tweet here from columbia eagle of
course was jd vance winning the
republican primary for senator in
ohio and there he is pictured right next
to donald trump and uh we've got some
info here from the washington post
former president donald trump is flexing
his political influence in this year's
republican primaries backing his favored
candidates in hotly contested statewide
and congressional races trump has
signaled that he believes a key
potential run for president in 24 is
showing that he can still shape the gop
i'm king of the endorsements trump told
the washington post on april 6th and
just to be clear here so he got one for
one in the senate endorsements uh 35 out
of 40 so far of his house endorsements
have worked and statewide race
endorsements six of seven and uh things
are looking good for that
trump thing that what are they they're
calling it ultra magnet ultra magna i
think that was an i think that was a
transformer ultra that was ultra magnus
ultra maga
is what they're calling it now spencer
there's something happening here with
these crazy republicans huh yeah i think
it's trumpimus prime actually
well look i mean it's really interesting
to me reasonable people on the right
have disagreements about what trump's
role ought to be going forward whether
2024 is what we're looking at or whether
he's kind of this king maker figure but
i think one thing that these
endorsements show is that there's one
wrong way to look at this and that's asa
hutchinson the governor i guess of
georgia i think who said you know trump
cannot be the future of our party
because he will only divide us further
right that will be he's this divisive
figure um and all of his issues these
new right issues like going hard on the
cultural war like trade protectionism
caring about immigration and doing
something about it right that these are
divisive issues i think that what we've
seen not just with these endorsements
but you know in virginia and places like
that that's the opposite of the case the
culture war issues are the issues that
bring us together when you show people
ordinary americans black white i don't
care male female i don't care gay
straight i don't care when you say to
them look these people want to come into
your classrooms they want to talk to
kindergartners about how they can change
their gender and change their sex
whether their parents agree or not right
people are appalled and we saw in
loudoun county how that galvanized uh
you know a red wave we're seeing now
that trumpism uh you know whatever you
think about trump the man himself
trumpism as a political platform is
hugely successful and i think that's the
direction the republicans got to go if
they want to win spencer i'm going to
clean it up for you before media matters
gets you it's arkansas arkansas asa
hutchinson not not georgia because
they're watching all the time and
they're ready to pounce so i'm doing you
a solid right there
generally speaking seeing a little
diversity on the right the fact that
there is this internal fight uh this is
good right
right again it's just normal people and
normal people happen to be diverse and
look different and think different and
we're all willing we're the side that's
willing to allow everybody to speak
their opinion and we want to debate back
and forth we want to come to the proper
conclusion and i'm so interested
interested to see what the next thing
they try to pull out of the bag because
we're winning and it seems like on every
single front the pendulum is starting to
swing back and i'm very curious to see
what their next attack move is because
they can't really go after and do this
whole orange man bad because he's really
not at the forefront right now he's
behind the scenes just saying you know i
like that one and people are responding
so we'll see what happens
uh alicia i sense though with 22 out of
22 he might put himself back in the
forefront of this thing that's what
pretty much that's what pretty much
everybody was saying and i was at
mar-a-lago a couple days ago with all
the crazy right-wingers of florida and
uh they were they debuted this dinesh
d'souza documentary about the election
uh 2000 mules was quite interesting and
i would recommend people see it whether
or not it makes an airtight case is
actually not even for me to say um but
this kind of nudges the idea that he's
going to jump back in right
oh yeah and people on the right like
yourself and ben shapiro are saying this
and then you have the new york times the
daily that did a whole episode about it
the other day which obviously they're
skewing to the left but what he's not uh
he's not only asking people like oh hey
what are your conservative principles or
are you you know a maga person he's
asking them their opinion on the 2020
election whether or not it was stolen
and apparently according to some
insiders he's even asking them would you
support me in 2024 i agree with that
everybody said that it's great that he
is able to have influence and the
majority of these candidates seem like
legitimate conservatives i just wish
that he would set aside 2024 endorse
somebody like desantis or nikki haley or
somebody else or maybe wait for a little
bit and then determine who he's going to
support and continue to endorse an
influence and maybe give some money on a
pac level to candidates across the
country and step out of it and not run
for president because i don't see that
as being a positive for the republican
party or the conservative movement i
think it's just possible that the
machine would not let him win no matter
what whatever whatever that means so
it's like is it more powerful he's
bringing in more money than the machine
right he's got more money in this last
year than the than the national
republican party has so he has the
coffers to kind of support himself here
and he has those die hard fans i just
don't think it is enough and we need to
get biden and kamala out of there and i
think that there's a lot of other
reasonable candidates that are on the
national stage that appeal to the
republican suburban women that didn't
vote for donald trump in 2020. i didn't
in 2016 i did in 2020 but unfortunately
those female voters stayed home because
we are different than men and we don't
like to see orange man saying certain
things or treating women in certain ways
and there's great conservative
candidates out there that he could
support and endorse and have influence
and be a king maker without being the
guy at the center stage in 2024.
actually i'm not sure about this but uh
i didn't vote for trump in 2016 either i
did in 2020. can i can i ask you guys
that did you guys all come around later
i'm not even i was 16 years old
i'm always the youngest person on these
things you gotta give me that i'm so
sorry you gotta step aside i'm the
youngest and i have the biggest hair